>> NOW, XI JINGPING APPEARS TO
BE DOING A RATHER DELICATE
DANCE ALONG THE ANCIENT SILK
ROAD IN UZBEKISTAN THE CHINESE
PRESIDENT MET WITH HIS RUSSIAN
COUNTERPART, VLADIMIR PUTIN,
PLEDGING MUTUAL SUPPORT AND
COOPERATION ON CORE INTERESTS,
BUT ONLY MR. PUTIN MENTIONED
THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
CNN'S IVAN WATSON REPORTS.
>> TWO, LEADERS UNITED BY THEIR
DISLIKE OF THE U.S..
SHE JINPING MAKING HIS FIRST
TRIP OUTSIDE OF COVID LOCKDOWN
CHINA AND MORE THAN TWO YEARS.
FACE TO FACE WITH HIS RUSSIAN
COUNTERPART, VLADIMIR PUTIN,
WHO QUICKLY ADDRESSES THE
ELEPHANT IN THE RUDE ROOM.
WE HIGHLY APPRECIATE THE
BALANCE POSITION OF OUR CHINESE
FRIENDS A CONNECTION OF THE
UKRAINIAN CRISIS.
WE UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTIONS
AND CONCERNS IN THIS REGARD.
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS ABOUT
RUSSIA'S DEADLY WAR IN UKRAINE.
A SHIFT IN TONE FOR THE LAST
TIME THESE TWO MEN MET, AT THE
START OF THE BEIJING WINTER
OLYMPICS IN FEBRUARY, SHE
JINPING AND PUTIN ANNOUNCED A
FRIENDSHIP WITH NO LIMITS, AND
CALLED FOR A NEW WORLD ORDER,
NOT DOMINATED BY WASHINGTON.
BUT ONLY WEEKS LATER, PUTIN
LAUNCHED HIS INVASION OF
UKRAINE, AND IT HAS NOT GONE
ACCORDING TO PLAN.
RUSSIA'S MILITARY, BATTERED,
ITS ECONOMY INCREASINGLY
ISOLATED.
PUTIN NOW NEEDS CHINA MORE THAN
EVER.
BUT, IN HIS PUBLIC COMMENTS,
THE CHINESE LEADER MADE NO
MENTION OF UKRAINE.
THE WHITE HOUSE ARGUES, WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS WAR, CHINESE
FRIENDSHIP DOES HAVE LIMITS.
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE CHINESE
DO ANYTHING OVERTLY TO SUPPORT
THE EFFORT BY MR. PUTIN INSIDE
UKRAINE.
CLEARLY, THEY HAVEN'T PUBLICLY
CONDEMNED IT, I THINK THE
CHINESE AS THEY WATCH WHAT'S
BEEN GOING ON, HERE THEY
RECOGNIZE HOW ISOLATED MOSCOW'S
FROM THE REST OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY, AND
RECOGNIZE THE ECONOMIC COSTS
AND CONSEQUENCES THAT THIS WAR
IS HAVING ON THE RUSSIAN
ECONOMY.
>> THANKS, IN LARGE, PART TO
THE ONGOING COVID LOCKDOWNS OF
ENTIRE CHINESE CITIES, THE
CHINESE ECONOMY IS ALSO TAKING
A BEATING.
SOMETHING SHE JINPING CAN'T
AFFORD TO IGNORE, AS HE
PREPARES TO GRANT HIMSELF A
THIRD TERM IN OFFICE.
THE CHINESE AND RUSSIAN NAVIES,
ARE CONDUCTING JOINT PATROLS IN
THE PACIFIC OCEAN, BUT THESE
TYPES OF SHOWS OF FORCE, HAVE
BEEN CHALLENGED BY THE FIERCE
RESISTANCE, DISPLAYED BY A MUCH
SMALLER MILITARY, FIGHTING ON
THE BATTLEFIELDS OF UKRAINE.
IVAN WATSON, CNN, HONG KONG.
AND LET'S BRING IN CNN'S
BEIJING BUREAU CHIEF STEVEN
JIANG, LIVE THIS HOUR IN THE
CHINESE CAPITAL.
STEVEN, IT'S JUST FASCINATING
TO SEE VLADIMIR PUTIN THANK MR.
XI FOR CHINA'S POSITION ON
UKRAINE, AND MR. XI NOT EVEN
MENTION IN UKRAINE.
THAT'S RIGHT MICHAEL, AS I
MENTIONED, IT DOES SHOW SOME
LIMITS IN THE SO-CALLED MOMENT
OF PARTNERSHIP AND ALSO SHOWS
THIS IMBALANCE IN THIS
RELATIONSHIP WITH JOHN,
INCREASINGLY CLEARLY BEING THE
GREATER POWER.
THAT'S WHY WELL SHE MADE NO
MENTION OF UKRAINE, PUTIN
DEFINITELY MENTIONED TAIWAN
WHICH IS CHINA'S MOST IMPORTANT
SO-CALLED CORE INTERESTS AND A
SOURCE OF HIS GROWING TENSIONS
WITH THE WEST.
ESPECIALLY THE U.S. AFTER THAT
CONTROVERSIAL VISIT BY NANCY
PELOSI.
SO PUTIN NOT ONLY PLEDGED
RUSHES CONTINUES PORT FOR
CHINA'S CLAIM AND POSITION,
EVEN WENT OUT OF ITS WAY TO
CONDEMN THE U.S. AND ITS ALLIES
FOR THEIR PROVOCATIVE ACTIONS
AGAINST CHINA IN THIS REGARD.
AND IF YOU READ BETWEEN THE
LINES, AND SHE JINPING ALSO
SAID HE'S WILLING TO WORK WITH
PUTIN TO SHOW THE WORLD THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF GREAT
POWERS, IN TERMS OF INJECTING
STABILITY INTO A WORLD OF
TURBULENCE.
AND THAT IS SEEN BY SOME AS A
SUBTLE OR NOT EVEN SO SUBTLE
REPROACH OF ASHA, BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY INVADING THEIR
NEIGHBORS NOT DOING THAT.
THE UNCERTAINTY AND ECONOMIC
FALLOUT FROM THAT WAR, OF
COURSE, HAS NOT BEEN GOOD FOR
THE ALREADY STRUGGLING CHINESE
ECONOMY.
THAT'S WHY SHE JINPING IS VERY
LIKELY GOING TO CONTINUE TO
STRADDLE, THAT, IS BROADLY
SPEAKING --
HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO OFFER
PRUDENT SUPPORT DIPLOMATICALLY
AND STRENGTHENING BILATERAL
TIES.
BUT HE'S NOT GOING TO MAKE
CHINA A SUBJECT OF WESTERN
SANCTIONS, BECAUSE CHINA
OBVIOUSLY HAS A MUCH BIGGER
TRADING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
WESTERN RUSSIA, AND ALSO THEY
CONTINUE TO ACCESS WESTERN
MONEY AND MARKETS.
IT'S ALSO WORTH NOTING THAT
FROM THE CHINESE RESPECTIVE,
THIS TRIP BY XI JINPING IS NOT
JUST ABOUT A SIGN OF RUSSIAN
TIES, IT'S WHETHER THEY'RE
TRYING TO HIGHLIGHT CHINA'S
GROWING INTEREST IN CLOUD IN
THE CENTRAL ASIAN REGION, AND
MANY NATIONS THERE OBVIOUSLY,
HAVE A VERY STRONG SUSPICION OF
PUTIN'S INTENTIONS IN THEIR
COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE IT HERE, THE
REALLY PUTTING OUT A PROPAGANDA
BLITZ.
HIS INTERACTIONS WITH OTHER
LEADERS IN THIS TRIP REALLY
SHOWING HOW CHINA HAS OTHER
INTERESTS AND --
TO TAKE CARE OF AS WELL.
MICHAEL?
>> ALL RIGHT STEVEN, APPRECIATE
THE UPDATES, STEVEN JIANG THERE
IN BEIJING FOR US.